there's been a couple times when she's
like I'm dancing like mommy and daddy
and she kind of is a little Channing
Tatum and Jenna Dewan Tatum adorable
daughter Everly definitely takes after
mom and dad et has been with a couple as
they opened up about their daughter over
the years she likes the tap dances we
got her little dancing shoes and she
just likes to like make noise all day we
can't get him off her she falls down all
the time she's not she's not watching
anything she's not watching TVs know
what she just wants to dance and run
around right now so I don't know if I'm
super bummed but I'm doing the very best
that I can and she's such a happy little
girl so we're doing something right
that's for sure
she loves anything with music music is a
big thing with her right now so it's a I
think it's probably gonna stay a big
thing with her just married you know my
my wife and her mom we we both really
music is a huge part of my life he's a
great diaper duty dad I will say that is
his thing he nails it every time and I'm
like here here you go changer and he's
okay he's willing he's great at it and
he actually likes it it's his time to
bond I'm really blessed man we got we
got a little nice little crazy little
family life that's super simple in love
it
[Music]